here is thomas soule
this is the interview that i did with
thomas soul in 2018 i asked him about
this very point that joe rogan just
referenced there where is it ever too
late to take back government power uh
and thomas sol well thomas ladies and
gentlemen in a area where the government
has taken on a bigger role than it's
supposed to i think one of the things
you hear all the time is it's sort of
too late i think a lot of people think
it's too late to take back that
government power no you
heaven's uh
during the reagan administration that
was the only time
i know of
when the federal register grew smaller
where they compiled all the laws that
have been passed in a given time
so it can be done it's not it's not it's
not uh it's not it's not
easy
but it can be done someone wants to
there was some issue with reagan was
discussing and someone said you know it
it's complicated he said it's not
complicated it's just not easy to do i
mean right now i i i one of the big
forces out here are talks about
affordable housing and they're
appointing
blue ribbon committees to look into why
there's no affordable housing and i
think that's that's like appointing a
blue ribbon committee to to to explain
why the ground is wet after after rain
i mean it's very simple if you prevent
people from building housing and the
population is growing you're going to
have a housing shortage and you won't
have affordable housing it's really you
know economics one during the first
first two weeks
what can we do right now i mean so
really this would be about just sort of
electing more libertarian minded
politicians then i mean is that really
the only way we can change things do you
think no i think the main thing people
have to know what the facts are
themselves
uh if if everyone knew what all the
facts were i think you'd have an
entirely different set of people elected
oh i love that line right it's like if
we could just inform people enough they
wouldn't be falling for this nonsense
right the the empty shell of a human
being justin trudeau sounding like a
nice guy with his nice suit and his nice
hair and his nice socks saying things
that sound so right if you had an
informed electorate people wouldn't fall
for it right if you perhaps this is
exactly why democrats here want everyone
to go to public schools and they're so
afraid of private schools and charter
schools and homeschooling because they
need people to be stupid maybe it's
really that simple they need a seriously
misinformed confused
dumb
dumb
uh group of people who have an a
historical take on who built this
country and what it's all about so that
they can continuously and continuously
attain power but underneath everything
soul is talking about there and man if
you have not seen that interview i hope
that you'll go watch it after let's
let's make sure we link to that original
interview uh in this video
um
and you can hear it actually in my voice
you know i never get nervous i can speak
in front of 10 000 people i do whatever
shows i do i never get nervous about any
of this stuff it's like this is what i'm
supposed to be doing so i don't feel
nerves related to any of this then when
i do stand up or anything else i never
feel nervous that's the only time i
think in my professional life i've ever
really been nervous you can hear it in
my voice there's almost like a frog in
my throat as i was talking because i was
just like man this is such a living
legend um but the point there is you
just have to have the will to do it
okay so we can have an informed populist
that'll that'll be good enough of us
will know what reality is we'll know
what our rights are we'll understand
what what these people are
but then you have to you have to have
the will it's complicated to do things
okay but so what we're going to do
things
we're going to make things happen we're
not going to let you take our rights and
you need to find enough people who are
willing to do that and occasionally you
are lucky enough to find a politician
who will do
just that and i guess those are the
people that we need more of right now
foreign